and he seems to be this seems to be like
a regular Monday spot for him these days
because his football morning in America
column that you can catch NBC sports.com
and pro football talk comm is just a
must read and this one that he filed up
to believe it 1:00 in the morning today
is no exception
also from football night in America and
Sunday Night Football Peter King back
here in the Rich Eisen show how are you
Peter rich so good to hear you you're on
NBC it's exciting it is exciting
look at us together this is great yeah
that's great
alright Peter when I saw your list of
guests yes and you tweeted it out yes
you had Peter King Carson Palmer Tom
Selleck I immediately thought of the old
Brian piccolo Gale Sayers I am third
Selleck one Palmer to King with that you
know what when I do my cast listing it's
always an order of appearance Peter I
don't know why that just doesn't happen
I can't break so let's start with that
with the draft and order of appearance
will be seeing the Commissioner I
imagine up first from his basement is
how did you nail down exactly where in
his house he would be announcing these
picks well you know if you know to two
weeks ago you were at the top of my
column because you basically said
because I I called you and I said hey I
hear there's an outside shop you know
it's it's a maybe it's definitely not
likely but an outside shot that Roger
Goodell will do this from his home you
know and you said hey in this stay home
era yes I what a great example that
would be the Commissioner doing the
draft from his home and so it went from
a long shot to a reality early last week
and I'm told that you know he has a very
nice basement in his home in Westchester
County New York yes
you would think that the Commissioner
the NFL would would have a fairly large
home and a and a well-appointed one and
so rich he is going to stand in his
basement I suppose there will be some
sort of podium but
the way that at home cameras now work
and and and I have one you have one I
mean most people in TV I think there are
many people in TV have them when you're
on one of those at home cameras you look
just like you're you're in the NBC
studio or something I mean it's
beautiful it looks absolutely perfect I
mean you watch Tom Hanks over the
weekend do SNL right and he didn't have
a jillion dollar camera I'm sure he had
one of these at home cameras but anyway
and and Roger is going to do that and
they are going to put basically a screen
behind him in which when the Bengals are
up they'll have 15 Bengals fans in these
little boxes you know these these things
that were getting used to watching now
these zoom videos right with everybody
being able to be called in and and when
he makes the pick people leave your
boots here whatever and he'll do that
for every pick in the first round a week
from Thursday well they will they be
able to be heard when he's introduced
Peter I don't know the answer to that
rich I assume you're asking me are they
gonna be able to boo the little Peter
I'm just it's an audio question it was
just a texture just a question about the
audio and I dog cast who knows we'll see
what happens but but most of the
reaction to that note my column today
has been wait a second how are we gonna
be able to boo and I can't help you
there I don't know you know Peter you've
seen it I've seen it everybody who boos
him when the Commissioner actually goes
into the crowd as he does every year
galore I mean it is it has been insane
you know and and on I proper to say
whoever some people who want a selfie
might have been the ones that have were
booing him and he comes off the stage
like can you sign this and he does yeah
actually every single time Peter King
here on the Rich Eisen show a simulcast
I'll cast going on right now on NBCSN
and and more so you're calling it a
virtual draft or people I guess are
calling it a virtual draft but you're
talking to people who are doing the
draft they don't think there's anything
virtual about it this is as real as it
gets
Peter how is it gonna work that's
something that you also shed a light on
again with Thomas Dimitrov of the
Falcons in your column I mean you you
mentioned you mentioned what you just
said to two general managers including
Tom telesco of the Chargers Telesto said
to me you know they're calling as a
virtual draft I don't get it it's the
real deal there's nothing fake about
this draft we got to live with this we
have to live with our decisions so yeah
the draft is going to be done
differently obviously it's going to be
done virtually but rich you know there's
going to be three different ways that a
general manager is going to be able to
call in his pick and and really one of
the coolest things and I look I'm just
getting used to I never heard him a
month ago but but one of the coolest
things that I was able to do I've been
trying to get Thomas dimitrov on my
podcast and I asked him on Friday hey
let's do zoom and so he said okay and he
said look I'll call it up on my phone
and I'll give you a little tour so the
first part of the of the conversation I
had with him was he was sitting out by
his pool and we were just talking about
the draft and I was gonna go and then he
said hey let me take you inside so
there's like seven minutes of Thomas
dimitrov showing Atlanta Falcons
draft headquarters you know on the 23rd
24th and 25th and it's if you go onto my
column and click on the video at the top
of the column you will be given a tour
of exactly how one team is going to
draft and and just so that you
understand the mechanics of it what will
happen essentially is that there will be
three different ways you can you can do
your pick
there's a private encrypted channel on
Microsoft teams that is going to be the
preferred method of teams to draft so
you know somebody could go on that
channel and inform the league Ken Fiori
who will be on Long Island at his home
he will be at ground zero of basically
moving the draft along
and they can inform either that way or
they can pick up the phone and call ken
Fiore and and tell them here's our pic
or finally you can go on a secure
conference call unmute your line which
will be active for all three days of the
draft just continuously it will never
never hang up you can go on that call
and literally say this is John Doe of
the Atlanta Falcons we select to atong
of Aloha with our first pick so that is
basically it there's as the NFL is set
from the start there will be multiple
redundancies and how exactly you can
draft that said what is the biggest
concern you've heard from from
evaluators and I just really think
there's a lot of concerns other than I
think most people like Ron Rivera told
me something really interesting he said
look we're figuring out what sort of our
line of demarcation when it gets to like
maybe the three-minute mark or
two-minute mark we're getting off the
phone and we're going to just be
concerned with getting our pick in he
said because the last thing we want to
do is screw up the delivery of the pick
and have somebody jump in there and I
don't believe the NFL is going to allow
that I think the NFL is going to be
understanding of some of those issues
but I think it probably probably is
going to cut down not massively but I
think it's going to cut down the number
of trades in the draft huh just because
people don't want to attempt it not you
they're not going to be used to this and
especially once it gets to be rounds
three through seven or four through
seven right and you only have five
minutes when you're on the clock and
your phone is lighting up or there's
somebody on zoom' on your staff who's
getting your call for another team and
then you got to talk it might be a
little bit too much for some teams to
handle I think as one team told me over
the weekend rich in especially when
shorter period of time we're gonna have
to be working if we have picked number
two ten once it gets to 203 and 204 if
we know we're gonna want to try
Beck we got to move aggressively at that
time to try to do so Peter King NBC
Sports joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show separating the wheat from the chaff
from what you're hearing in terms of the
rumor mill with ten days to go for the
draft there's a lot of chaff out there
Peter but what what are you hearing
about surprises what are you hearing as
a possibility atop this draft that we
might not be expecting right now well
probably the thing that surprised me the
most in 8 or 10 conversations Friday and
Saturday was how much and again this is
a little bit down in the weeds for
people who want my next 5 sentences to
be about quarterback but I I assumed
going into my weekend that that the vast
majority of the teams had Jeffrey okuu
to the Ohio State corner number one and
I was told and this is this was backed
up to me to that there's a lot of teams
in the league or fcj Henderson the
Florida Corner ranked ahead of Okuda so
you could I that's one of the reasons
why everybody thinks that the Lions want
to dump out of that Pickett 3 that
there's not a single player that they're
in love with but if anybody is let's say
the Chargers or you know or or Miami or
some team that maybe we're not expecting
Jacksonville which I heard really wants
to give Minshew a shot and isn't totally
focused on a quarterback high but but is
it possible that somebody will be so in
love and a little bit they want to be
absolutely sure they can get them either
Hergert or target Aloha couldn't move up
with Detroit to number 3 you know that
is possible but but I I also think as I
told somebody this weekend I said hey
listen Tom Thomson let's go the Chargers
has not made a draft weekend trade for
the last three years and so I think he's
made only one trade that involves a
draft pick that was two years ago he
traded a seven for Cardale Jones but but
I do think rich mostly mostly
the Detroit is is where I think the
traffic really is probably going to
start and then that's where I want to
start unpacking what you just said there
Peter because you know I know Okuda may
not be atop the corner back draft board
for for all teams and and that might be
a reason why the Lions would want to get
out of three but they I mean my gosh
there's so many transformative players
potentially from Isiah Simmons to any of
the tackles to any of the pass rushers
outside of chase young that the Lions
could could use the third overall pick
on but that said you know the to a
market is really what might drive that
pick being the domino the big domino to
fall here rich I think the big question
yeah is what is the to a market right
that's the question I mean I I don't I
don't know what it is I really don't
know what it is you know you have a guy
who is and you know fos our friend of
Stephen Ross Mike Tannenbaum say I think
it would be irresponsible to take two in
the top ten in the draft you know coming
off all of his injuries and I totally
get it I've had so many Miami fans say
what in the world are you talking about
the Dolphins have been pointing to 2a
for the last two years or the last year
and a half and I said well that kind of
changed didn't it last fall when he got
another high ankle sprain that required
surgery and when he had a very serious
hip injury that required major surgery
so you can't tell me that the market for
Toa
in April of 2020 is the same as the
market for tool was in September of 2019
life changes so and again Miami might
trade up and and trade a passel of picks
to get up to number three I don't know
but I just know that that that is going
to be as I spelled out my column today
14 years ago
the Dolphins had a gigantic decision to
make
risk signing drew brees coming up major
shoulder surgery may not be ready for
the start of the season or take the
safer guides Dante Culpepper
well that decision turned out to be a
horrible one by Nick Saban and the
Dolphins and it in fact led to Sabin at
the end of that year leaving Miami
imagine how the course of football
history has been changed if he signed
her agrees you don't imagine how the
Patriots history might have changed if
Nick Saban signed Drew Brees but I'm
just saying that just the same way that
that decision was huge for the franchise
in 2006 they have another quarterback
injury decision to make in 2020 that is
the biggest story of this dress ya know
you know you're hearing from team two of
from Leigh Steinberg to also Trent
Dilfer
agent and throwing coach that tua is as
great as he's ever been that he looks as
great as he's ever been and you're
seeing the video that came out I mean
that the arm strength is there I guess
what I just I just have two things to
say about that right if you were a guy
throwing coach and you were working with
him for a long time what would you say I
know I number one I did I know that
number to number two in number two if he
was hobbled in any way shape or form you
think they'd released the video well I
mean you could see you could see that
he's no I'm not blaming them they're
Leigh Steinberg Chris Cabot that those
are his agents and they are excellent
agents okay but but that doesn't address
what so many teams wonder about which is
still going to be able to play twelve or
fifteen years if you draft the
quarterback and it and want them to be
your franchise quarterback you're not
taking them so you turn that position
over again in five years yeah again he
doesn't look hobbled to me though Peter
I mean he looks I'm not trying I am NOT
saying he's hobbled in any way right but
all I'm saying all I'm saying is that I
mean you have to consider the injury
history on this guy you just do men
anybody who doesn't is really not being
respond
I understand the wave the flag for two a
thing I and I if I work for her for them
I would be doing exactly the same thing
but there's one thing to say I love to
with a football player there's another
thing to say okay we're guaranteeing him
30 million he's going to be our
quarterback and and and and you know
what if I had all the knowledge that the
Dolphins had and their doctors stood up
and said I stake my reputation on this I
take them and I wouldn't worry about it
but I don't know what team doctors
inside the Miami Dolphins or Chargers or
whoever are saying about to it yeah and
then we'll see how the draft goes last
one for you we'll see how the draft goes
with the veteran quarterbacks we're
still there I don't think I've ever
started a sentence with anybody this way
certainly with you Peter but I heard
what Cam Newton told Chris Paul and I
heard what Jameis Winston told Fox News
it sounds like a mad lib but they both
seemed resigned to not getting a job
before May right now Peter would you
agree with that assessment I mean what I
first of all I don't understand this
Jameis Winston is one thing he's pleased
totally healthy III mean I think he
would much more easily be signed
somewhere by somebody now but this is
not because teams don't necessarily as
that I've seen in 36 years covering the
NFL you can't fully vet Cam to your
liking right now because your team
doctor cannot get his hands on Cam
Newton and you can't sit in the room and
talk to him now you obviously can can
have a zoom chat if you want I you know
I think it's pretty natural why this is
gonna take a while at least with Cam now
look I've said this I think there are
multiple teams
if I were them I'd want Jameis Winston
on my team but you know it takes two to
tango Peter thanks for the time as
always I have a feeling we'll be doing
this again same time next week when it
is actually draft we hope we do hope we
do rich thank you look forward to it at
Peter underscore King on Twitter and of
course check out his football morning in
America column on NBC Sports pro
football talk.com